hey this is presh talwalkar
happy 2018.
to celebrate the new year i want to
share a math trick that got really
popular and even got coverage in places
like the telegraph
follow the directions carefully and do
the calculations in sequence
use a calculator to check your work and
press the equal sign after each step
the trick works only in the year 2018.
get started with your shoe size
round down to the nearest whole number
we don't want any half sizes
now multiply by 5
then add 50
then multiply by 20.
add one thousand seventeen
if you have already had your birthday
this year add one more
otherwise do nothing
finally subtract the year that you were
born
the answer will be your shoe size
followed by your age
amazing
please share if this effect worked for
you
the more interesting question
mathematically is why does it work
can you figure out the algebra
give it a try and when you're ready keep
watching for my explanation
so let's go through each step we start
with your shoe size which i'll denote by
the variable s
we multiply by 5 to get 5s
then we add 50 which results in 5s plus
50.
now we need to multiply by 20 so we take
the entire term 5s plus 50 and multiply
it by 20.
the 20 will distribute to each of these
terms
so we end up with 100 s plus 1 000.
now we add
1017 to get 100s plus 2017.
if you have already had your birthday
this year add one more which would
result in 100s plus 2018.
we finally need to subtract the year
that you were born
so there are two cases if you have not
had your birthday this year
this will be 100s
plus 2017 minus the year that you were
born and since you have not had your
birthday already
2017 minus the year that you were born
will be your age so we end up with 100s
plus your age if you have had your
birthday
then when you take 100s plus 2018 minus
the year that you were born
2018 minus the year that you were born
will be your age so this will be 100s
plus your age
so the variable s has been shifted over
two decimal places and then the
remaining two will be your age a two
digit number so that's why the answer
will be your shoe size followed by your
age
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description
you can support me on patreon and you
can also catch me on social media either
at mindyourdecisions or at
preshtalwalker